There are some people who go to great lanes
to look like their favorite Disney characters.
And then there are others who look like the
animated characters without even trying.
These everyday people and celebs...
...are the carbon copies of some of the most
popular Disney princesses, princes, heroes and villains.
If you're new to our channel, don't forget to subscribe.
And please give this video a big thumbs up.
Because today, we're sharing: '10 People Who Twinned With Disney Characters By Accident'.
Ukrainian Judge & Ursula.
This Ukrainian judge is the spitting image
of one of Disney's most evil villains.
Here name is Alla Bandura
and she's a dead ringer for Ursula.
The half-octopus, half woman character
from The Little Mermaid.
When this photo of the judge was posted online...
...many people couldn't help but noticed
she looked like Ursula's long-lost twin sister.
With her dramatic eye-makeup, her bright-red lipstick and her black and grey hair...
...Alla and Ursula are definitely twinning.
Lily Cole & Merida.
There's a reason why everyone thinks
Lily Cole looks a lot like Merida from "Brave".
The Disney princess was actually inspired
by the English model and actress.
When you look at photos of Lily and Merida side by side,
you can see how much these two look just alike.
They both have same the wild and untamed curly hair,
the same pouty lips...
...and the same big and expressive eyes.
Joe Jonas & Aladdin.
Joe Jonas stepped out on
the red carpet and...
...accidentally twinned
with the Disney character Aladdin.
With his hair a bit longer, Joe looks like
he and Aladdin were separated at birth.
They even have the same thick eyebrows
and the same big, brown eyes.
All Joe needs is a purple vest
and a pair of white Harem pants...
...to really become Aladdin's doppelganger.
Twinning with Flash from Zootopia.
You probably never thought it would be possible for a human to look exactly like Flash from Zootopia.
But boy, were you wrong!
This girl looks exactly like the friendly and adorable character right down to her goofy facial expression...
...and the shape of her eyes.
If Zootopia ever makes to Broadway...
...this girl should definitely
play the role of the lovable sloth.
Carl from "Up's" twin.
Doesn't this guy look almost identical to
Carl Fredricksen from Up?
He's practically the animated character's real-life twin.
If we didn't know any better, we would think Carl was definitely created with this man's image in mind.
They have the same glasses, the same nose,
the same white smile and the same bushy hair.
Chris Hemsworth & John Smith.
Back when actor Chris Hemsworth was
rocking a long and full head of hair...
...he was a dead ringer for the character
John Smith in the movie Pocahontas.
He may not be an English explorer...
...but Chris definitely has the same blue eyes, perfectly styled hair and the same chiseled jawline as John.
With a live-action remake of this movie is in the works...
...Disney doesn't have to look too far to
cast Pocahontas' love interest.
Jean Sarkozy & The Prince.
Without even knowing it, Jean Sarkozy is
twinning with the prince of Beauty and The Beast.
Jean, who is the son of the former president of France,
is definitely the prince's lookalike.
They've the same gorgeous head of hair, the same face shape and the exact same bushy eyebrows.
The only difference is the color of their hair.
But all Jean needs is a pair of blue contact lenses
to complete his transformation into the prince.
Cruella de Vil's
real-life twin.
For some people, being compared to Cruella de Vil
of 101 Dalmatians, isn't a compliment.
But we have to hand it to this lady, because she is definitely giving Cruella a run for her money.
The woman was photographed looking
exactly like the puppy-obsessed villain.
She has the same multi-colored hair...
...and we even spot a bit of fur
on the hood of her winter coat.
Elsa's long-lost sister.
There are many everyday people who think
they look like Elsa from the movie Frozen.
But we think this girl takes the cake.
She obviously thinks she looks a lot like
the "Frozen" character too.
She took this photo next to a cutout of Elsa,
and we have to admit, the resemblance is uncanny.
They have the same facial expression, the same beautiful eyes and the exact same smile.
All this girl needs is a beautiful blue dress
to really transform her into the Disney star.
Khal Drogo & Scar.
How crazy is the resemblance between Jason Momoa's "Game of Thrones" charactor, Khal Drogo...
...and Scar from "The Lion King"?
The Warlord's tan skin and dark hair and features,
really resembles Scar's appearance.
Even though, Khal is a humand, and Scar is a Lion...
...that doesn't change the fact that
these two are the spitting image of each other.
Don't you agree?
Do you know anyone who looks like a
real-life Disney character?
React in the comment section down below,
and don't forget to give this video a big thumbs up.